after listening to
after listening to many of your
interviews and speeches as well as
reading your three books I think we can
agree that people on Wall Street in
politics and inside intelligence
agencies have blatantly broken the law
removing them from positions of power
restructuring the executive branch and
administrative state would be a
significant step in the right direction
my question is how are you going to
convince voters that you will hold these
criminals accountable for their actions
if there's no accountability the same
people will continue to attack America
from a different angle I appreciate that
Hannibal so
I agree with you that I want to move
forward as a country but we cannot move
forward until we have settled the open
wounds of the past otherwise they're
just going to keep cropping up and in
dangerous and ugly ways so I'll just
give you some examples of how I'm going
to sew those wounds over so that we can
move forward as a country okay
so first of all we need to restore the
idea of I alluded to this in the
beginning government that tells the
truth to its citizens
who lied about the origin of the
covid-19 pandemic
who lied about what we knew about
vaccines and the risks associated with
myocarditis and the mandates and school
lockdowns who understood the extent of
pervasive government technology company
relationships to be able to do through
the back door what the government could
not do through the front door who
actually understood the systematic truth
but suppression of a hunter-biden
corruption story on the eve of a
presidential election that you had your
social media accounts locked if you dare
to even send in a direct message
who wants to know the truth about
January 6th I'd like to know exactly how
many federal agents were on site that
day I'm not to say it's one conclusion
or another just give me the facts who
wants to know the truth about where I
was earlier this week
the Nashville Shooters Manifesto
my view is tell us the truth what I see
in the government today it's like the
it's like the Jack Nicholson character
in A Few Good Men right he said you
can't handle the truth you need me on
that wall no we don't need you on that
wall and yes we can handle the truth
and the people who have systematically
lied and broke the law while doing it
who used our money to do through the
back door fund taxpayer funded research
in Wuhan China for a form of research
that was banned here in the United
States
that's criminal and that deserves full
accountability
I'll tell you another issue which we're
tussling about right now we're gonna
it's gonna be a tough one to sort
through election integrity
okay
many on the left say raising this
question is itself a threat to democracy
here's my
truce on this issue
single day voting
on Election Day
make it a holiday
voter IDs
government issues IDs matched to the
voter file paper ballots
do that deal I will do my part as the
leader of the Republican party and the
leader of this country but to the
Republican party to say we are done
complaining about election Integrity if
we deliver those Basics that are
achievable that should not be
controversial and so I am hopeful that
what seems impossible today think about
the unbridgeable divides
we can do this
it's not
complicated
it's simple but it is hard
in that it's not easy okay and that's
what it's going to take is it's not some
clever
plot that we have to construct it just
takes a leader with the spine to stand
up and say we will speak the truth we
will speak the truth when it is hard I
will issue an executive order on day one
requiring the entire federal government
anybody who pressured a private actor a
company or otherwise to do something
that the government could not do on its
own we're going to at least publish it
so the public can see it roll that log
over let's see what crawls out
sunlight is the first step
to actual accountability and we need
accountability in order to heal as a
nation thank you for that question
Hannibal I appreciate it thank you so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]